[Music]
Runk you know uh if you haven't watched
this special watch the special chia.com
it's called grow or die um love you for
watching it love you for downloading it
uh go stream at a chia.com uh I will be
in Oxnard coming up and I will be in
Philadelphia I will be in Reading I will
be in Baltimore this weekend and I will
be
in um Richmond Virginia this weekend and
Trenton New Jersey and uh uh oh actually
tickets are live now for Sacramento
California Phoenix El Paso Texas and
Albuquerque uh with the promo code don't
push me um and then Friday is available
for everyone so go get those good
tickets now and uh right now we will
have the next episode of
[Music]
congratulations
conat right now we will have the next
episode of congratulations that is what
we will
have um just got off of the plane uh
fresh out of Florida extra paper scoop
that up um was in Florida Florida
absolutely Bonkers huh Florida's
Bonkers Florida's Bonkers every I I will
tell you
this just landed from Fort Myer or I was
in Fort Myers there's no direct flight
from Fort Myers to LAX natch
natch why because what is Fort Meers
what is it besides the guy that killed
gab petito the home of that guy and then
also the home of where that little girl
who was actually 45 years old uh and
tormented the parents was adopted you
know it's on Netflix that documentary
whatever the documentary is the little
girl that was adopted but she was
actually 40 or something and they still
don't know if she's 40 or 12 whatever
that thing is anyway that's where I was
this past weekend and so I went to um
Myer dry yes dude went to uh to much
traveling yes dude so was that um maybe
I'll just angle this a little
differently the
air um but I was in Florida whenever I'm
in Florida I will tell you this 35 to
40% EDC will be happening doesn't matter
what city I'm in in
Florida I'm kind of I'm I'm there when
when I whenever I go to Florida there's
some Festival that's happening I've gone
now it's been EDC four times Ultra once
and then one time it was like a pirate
festival Festival Festival sorry I was
being Spanish for a little bit I was
being Mexican a little bit
Festival um no but there was a pirate
one in Tampa which is the worst one
gasparella
right and
uh you ever get a song stuck in your
head for no reason dude I haven't heard
that song since 2001 you remind me of a
Westside
Story growing up in Spanish
living life just like a movie
[Music]
star by the way I had no idea I knew the
words to that pretty sure those are the
words but I do dude
[Music]
Mar did you ever start singing a song
and you and you're like well I'll just
go for as long as until I know the words
and then you realize you know the whole
song and you're just like for three and
a half minutes singing by yourself and
you finish and A Tear comes down your
cheek and you're like whoa hold on a
second I'm a
singer you're just like I'll just stop
when I don't know it leave me on leave
me on leave me on babyon oh I know the
whole thing dude you're like and I will
walk 500 and you're like I certainly
don't know miles miles and I will and we
walk 500 what more more and you just and
you're like and but to and you're like
that's all I know but then you're like
but to be the man who walks 500 miles to
fall down at your door and you're like
that's all I know for sure I don't know
the syllables that they do and then
you're just
like but you just know it when I wake up
and I know I'm going to be I'm going to
be the man who wakes up next you how do
I know that
[__] I heard this song four times when I
was like 11 why do I even know it's The
Pretenders but you do it and whenever I
go to Florida it's a festival 40 to 50%
guaranteed a festival dude I was there
and it was EDC and I put on a shirt that
was ripped a little bit and I thought hm
you're pushing it Chris you're pushing
it then I realized it was EDC in Orlando
and I thought well if anyone makes fun
of my outfit it'll probably be somebody
with you know Underoos on and butterfly
wings so with like
you know under eye purplle neon shits so
I could just be like oh yeah well why do
you wear why you have that on I had a
slam built in I had the built-in
slam so I was in
Orlando uh did a show in Orlando and
stayed an extra day in Orlando my ma my
tour manager was like let's go to here's
what happened dude I was going to do
Orlando and then Tampa and then
Fort Meyers for some
reason Tampa for some reason we didn't
get the date because uh this other comic
got it first and so my tour manager
[__] me he really [__] me man and he
[__] the people of Tampa except for
your fans of the other comedians that's
good for them but um so he he was like
well let's just go to Fort Meyers after
Orlando we'll stay there for an extra
day I go like this stop right there hold
your horses that's the place where gab
potito's boyfriend friend is from and he
killed her and that's also the place
where that little old woman who was
adopted that was pretending she was a
little girl to her parents that were
that adopted her so like let's stay in
Orlando an extra day and he goes I don't
know man and I I say pull the trigger
we're going to stay in Orlando extra day
and we did it i'm guess what I'm doing
now guess what I'm starting to do I'm
starting to make
decisions I'm starting to make decisions
dude I'm a very I'm I'm the kind of guy
who look I know what I
want I you know I I I have a Clear
Vision right but are but sometimes are
you like me when you have a Clear Vision
you're like God I want [__] you
know I want a jean jacket I want a light
green Jack I want a light jean jacket
right like maybe you saw somebody
wearing it you're like I want to get a
jean jacket that's light and kind of
boxy and you're like I got a plan so
where do you go you go to a place you
think might have a jean jacket you go by
you say yeah it's fall you know I could
wear it well into winter I could couple
it up with a flannel might like look one
of those guys in Supernatural you know
maybe I look like Jensen Ackles who the
[__] knows or the other guy right maybe
I'm going to be looking like I'm going
to be haunting a wind dingo maybe I'm
going to be looking like that maybe I'm
looking for a lady in a in the water
right I don't know
but I might look that dope when I'm
going to wear a boxy light denim
jacket picture me in pittsb at the
outskirts of Pittsburgh picture me right
under the
Moonlight looking for a
wendo right or a Lady in the Water you
know what I
mean so
um you go in with a plan you go to a
place that you think might have a nice
wend dingo hunting jean
jacket and you get there and the sales
guy approaches you and he says hey how
can I help you
say I want a
light denim jacket that's boxy and he
says
oo and right there you know your plans
are getting upended dude right there you
know you're walking out of that place
with a different jacket or maybe just
pants ooh you know we actually we had
those last you know those are out those
were in all the supernatural guys were
wearing them and now let me show you
what we have and you're walking out of
there with some trench coat Mafia style
[__] you know what I mean you don't the
plan it gets
shook right you go in with a plan you
think it's clear and you
leave with pants right okay so
that's been happening to me a lot in my
life I go in with a plan now I'm not
talking about you know when it comes to
food I know what I if I want pretzels
I'll be godamn if I'm not eating
pretzels right if I want a burger I'll
be godamn if someone's [__] that up
for me if I want burgers how about sushi
I say you know what you get sushi I'm
getting a burger I'm clear with my with
my food but when it comes to anything
else I could be going to hunt a wendo
and come back with like a new car right
playing hands get uprooted and
shook but I stopped that this
month you know how how hard it is to
listen to yourself to just go like this
wait hold on a second me what what did I
want
again yes that's what I wanted and then
you look at someone's eyes and you say
no I'm not going to Fort Meers a day
early that's
hard we all used to be like that when we
were kids you know and we lose that [__]
we lose it when we were kids we wanted
chocolate that was all that was on our
minds we wanted some cool magnets we saw
in a store that was all on our minds you
know and we didn't stop thinking about
those magnets so we got those [__]
Magnets or like you know our parents
just were like no you
know but man when you become an adult
people could just sway you dude hold on
to that [__] hold on to that [__] dude
hold on to that [__] picture me under
the Moonlight outskirts of Pittsburgh
just hunting wendo in a light jean
jacket with [__] a nice flannel under
it or even so a flannel tied across my
waist like a really really like a
fashion move but also like oh maybe the
flana was too hot and the Jean Jack is
less hot so he had to tie it around his
waist he just put the jean jacket on
that's the right temp when he's walking
around looking for a
Wango
but yeah I started watching
Supernatural let me tell you something
man I was talking to my tour
manager I knew it too I was talking to
Lulu who I take on the road with me
fantastic comedian and my tour manager
Enrique and I
know here's something I
know I started watching Supernatural
just cuz it was on Netflix I just I'm
like you know what I like that guy I
like the Jensen dude right so I start
watching
it okay I'm watching the show now look
let me just tell
you it's got nine seasons of it on
Netflix all right so I look at it I'm
like holy [__] this show is on for nine
seasons and then I Google it it's been
on 15 Seasons I don't know why these
streaming services will do this but
it'll be like hey do you love this show
Pawn Stars great here's three seasons of
it one nine and 11 and you're like
huh you know oh yeah you love you know
Hulu will be like oh you love Family Guy
here's season two through four and then
20 and you're like what about the middle
[__] and they're like nah I don't know
why they obviously have a deal with the
[__] if you have a deal with it just at
least consecutively have the you know
it's like on a plane when you're like oh
what do they have you ever click on TV
shows when you're in a plane and you go
to click TV shows and you look in the in
the in the catalog and it's like oh they
got the c word with Laura Lin what was
it on Showtime or some [__] oh let's
start watching that that might I think
that was actually critically acclaimed
and it's like season 2 episode 4 and
season 2 episode 5 season 2 episode 6
that's what they have on the plane like
you're some [__] that's just going to
in the mid you're like you're just going
to be sitting upright eating
peanuts never having watched the seaword
before just picking oh yeah okay I'll
watch the seaword I I watch the l l did
they make a show called The L Word
too what the [__] man just say the whole
word in the thing the c word and the L
word just call the show cancer call the
show
lesbians that's so we know what it
is but yeah I'm I'm on the plane dude
right and I'm gonna watch [__] uh
uh what's the show with the
[__] who cares you know what I'm
saying airplanes have odd episodes of TV
shows if you go into the catalog of
stuff they never have starting with the
pilot no I know Supernatural I know I
started started watching
Supernatural but I started watching on
Netflix and I'm like dude this show is a
perfect show to watch on the plane why
because it's bad
but I like
it that's the best plane watching
shows bad but you like it like you don't
[__] turn on you know uh killers of
the flower moon on a plane you want to
watch it an iMac the biggest screen Poss
although I'm not one of those guys
that's like nah you got to go see it in
the theater right you got to see it on a
big the bigger the screen the better
like there are guys like that try
to you know go to the one in [__]
there's one in a Hollywood where you you
can go and there's it's 70,000 feet
up and 150 million feet
across it's a it's called CH
Cinema it's so wide and it doesn't go up
that
high it's the Chad Multiplex over in
Burbank dude
yeah it's [__] awesome dude the scre
yeah you know I get that name right why
cuz the screen looks like a Chad you
know what a Chad is yeah yeah it's a
penis that's wider than it is tall it's
like a can of
tuna
anyway um okay so go to the Chad
Multiplex to go see killers of
FL yeah dude we oh man I was with Dan
last night we went to go see uh killers
of flower mood at uh the CH Multiplex
man oh [__] it was awesome dude that
screen was so
wide anyway
um I uh I thought about making a movie
actually I'm gonna get the
supernatural but I thought about making
a movie where someone's possessed and
and there's like an
exorcism but like it's like real it's
not like the
[__] I think a good movie would be if
you didn't know if the person was
actually had a demon in them or if they
were a crazy
person and and he gets an exorcism and
he thinks he's better he either thinks
he's better or he's better and you don't
know the whole time even at the end of
the movie you're like like it Sparks
debate you're like were they do you
think that there was a demon in him was
it a horror movie or was it is a movie
about mental issues I don't make that
movie dude and they get an exorcist and
The Exorcist is like pretty lack lack a
days of go and [__] anyway I'm getting
off topic but my
uh
Supernatural it's a bad show and here's
the thing I I didn't want to tell
Enrique or Lulu that I was going to
watch it because they were going to make
me mad the way that they were going to
say that it was a good show and I know
that about my friend friends I know my
friends do you know why I know my
friends cuz I know my enemies and your
friends are your enemies okay your
friend shouldn't be that close like Mike
Tyson said a man who is a friend to
everyone is an enemy to himself
right I don't know if I believe that but
that sounds [__] dope so I wasn't
going to tell them that I was watching
Supernatural cuz I didn't
want Lulu to be like oh that's one of my
top five favorite shows and I didn't
want Enrique to be like oh it's
badass cuz it's a bad show and I wanted
to keep that to my chest I wanted to
keep that in here you
understand I wanted to keep it right
here I wanted to be close to the chest I
wanted to
be I wanted to watch Supernatural know
it was bad and like it on my doo
dude it was not a sharing show what'd he
do though what did he do though first
[__] chance he got he says you know
what I'm watching [__] dude he betrays
himself a man that is friendly to
everyone is an enemy to himself that's
what I did right there I was being way
too friendly to my friends and I was an
enemy to myself and now I can't roll on
my doo and keep it close to the chest
about how I like to watch Supernatural
because it's bad and I like
it does any of this make [__] sense
dude yes
if you don't get it then I don't want
you a part of this
cult Jared letto out there climbing the
Empire State Building dude chill
bro I'll get to that later dude he even
start at the bottom and go all the way
at the top he did 18 floors in the
middle you [__] what I'll get to
it but my point is I told him and I
betrayed myself I told him I was
watching superal and sure enough and R
goes oh it's badass and I said no but
you know it's a bad show right and he
says no way it's [__] awesome dude
there's 15 Seasons obviously it's
awesome and I was like you can like it
but it's
bad he's like how about Sam though I'm
like dude Sam's the worst character you
like Dean he said I said I
guess I don't be knowing the names of
characters in TV shows also by the way
until it's
like season 4
and then Lulu came along and Enrique yo
he watches Supernatural she goes that's
one of my top five favorite shows of all
time and I said to watch because you
like it but you know it's bad right and
she says get the [__] out of here dude I
how am I supposed to sit with
[__] that are going to
like think that it's a whatever dude it
doesn't matter the show's bad I like
watching it it's you know there's not
enough colors in it
it's dark and [__] and green and brown
but anyway picture me like
that so I
digress I'm watching it on the plane I
download it on my
phone having a good
time the thing about Jared letto
is and I know you're with
me everyone's going to be like wow right
we have to remember something dude just
because something looks wow doesn't mean
it is
wow there's no such thing as
magic right there's
trickery that's all there is there's
trickery
also climbing the Empire State Building
is illegal period unless you ask
beforehand and pay people and you're
famous that's some rich guy [__] I am
not down with that [__] I am not down he
climbed 18 floors in the middle of the
[__] no look I'm not saying it's not
hard okay I'm not saying it's not hard
it is hard but just cuz something is
hard doesn't mean it's good or cool okay
or worth
doing case in
point
break dancing that's hard you think I
could do this
[__] I can't do
itar I can feel
you I can't you know what I'm talking
about whatever that song
is
here hold my jacket it's a disrespectful
but
um it's not cool to do break dancing I
don't care right I don't care how baggy
your clothes are or how many [__]
Kobe Bryant jerseys you have you know
what I'm talking about you look
stupid it looks cool to some people but
to me you're just somebody who's dressed
in way too comfortable clothes and a
backwards hat and I can't tell if you're
a man or a woman
right
um so uh yeah what the [__] was I saying
about Jared Leto so the dude we don't
say his name though here at this podcast
we actually don't so I'm saying it right
I'm say I said it but I don't I don't
say his name but you know I'm talking
about the guy who climbed the Empire put
J but we don't say his name right
so he climbed up 18 floors of the Empire
State Building everyone was like whoa
look what he's doing dude first of all
he was strapped in and I'm not saying
it's still not impressive or [__]
whatever it's still hard dud don't do
that you're a rich guy
and you don't you don't just climb 18
stories you got to climb the whole thing
otherwise that ain't [__] I don't give a
[__] all right period And honestly if
I'm being completely honest I'm not
going to talk about it anymore but I
will say oh dude you know what did
happen I got sidetracked because this is
what I really wanted to talk about
on the way to Orlando Florida which Al
which is the home of Disney World which
is the home of EP Epcot Center what is
Epcot Center now I don't know I don't
have a [__] clue all I remember is a
commercial when I was younger where that
big ball was there was right there and
the helicopter flew by and Mickey was on
the top of it waving I said hey Ma how
did HEI Mickey get up there I don't
remember the end of that story but I did
ask her
that Epcot Center Orlando Florida I'm on
the way way to Orlando on the plane the
plane starts to take
off
dude this is
real I had a
full-blown panic
attack like a
level I would say a level
nine panic attack
dude
yes
dude dude a level n panic attack took
off couldn't get signed on to the Wi-Fi
so I go like
this all of a sudden the stress of the
world the stress of the mind gets to me
and I couldn't sit up straight dude I
was going like this I couldn't sit up
straight and I was like dude have
youever had a panic attack where you
pass out I've had one before that and
this I didn't know if I pass out or
not dude I I go like this you're like
trying to it's like when when in Ace
Ventura the second one when he gets shot
with the [__] darts and he's just
like four darts is too many like dude or
whatever it
is I was like I was the guy next to me
must have thought I was was like
transforming into an elephant cuz I was
just like I couldn't you ever faint
sitting down dude like standing up is
one thing you'd be like oh yeah cuz like
it was it's it's it's work to stand up
it's not work to sit down I'm not even
uncomfortable I'm in first class and I'm
just I all the stress from everything
from my family to work everything all of
a sudden couldn't get online I couldn't
get online and I just oh my heart goes
oh and I just start
going I grabb the dude I this is
so I come to so I don't know it's not
like I knew I passed out but I come to
so it was like one of those things I
didn't know if I passed out or not but I
come to
pants soaking wet and I'm like great
pissed
myself dude soaking wet from my waist to
my knees and I'm like great titied
myself like straight like
absolutely soaked okay like not to where
you're like Ah that's a lot but it'll
dry I'm going to
Orlando like oh I'm I'm wet guy
now like I'm wet pants man
you know on the plane this is who I am
if you don't know I'm comedian crystalia
I'm hey the guy with the wet pants over
there that's who I that's my identity in
this cylindrical tube right
now and I go pants soaked and I [__]
I'm like did I just piss my
pants and then I look and there's an
empty cup glass and I was like oh yeah I
asked for
water I think I must have spilled this
water on my
penis and it's not
piss in the
meantime there's a guy next to me and
I'm just like what is he
thinking just all the
Imagine in my head I'm like please don't
know who I am you know because I just
sit
down all right we'll be in Orlando in
four
hours all right D is being all of a
sudden I'm just
like and just pouring [__] water all
over my
balls and I go and I couldn't I couldn't
sit up
straight I if somebody were telling me
this I would think they were
exaggerating and I I wasn't even you
know I was this was the best part I was
this is how you know it was a true level
9 panic attack I wasn't even
scared
this is the best dude I wasn't even
scared of anything at all because all I
was focused on was trying to sit
up like if it were a level eight I would
be like am I
dying but I couldn't even get to that
because I was dealing with the most
granular purest you know what I mean
functional thought hey hey me sit
up do you
understand I was
over wet [__] from the waist to knees
just I dude I finally set up and I go I
hit the thing the gay flight attendant
came up cuz they're always gay and he's
like hey how can I help you and I say
hey can I um can I have water and I I
didn't know if I was going to pass out
again so I said I'm having a panic
attack you just need to keep bringing
water he just okay did you take your
meds and I look down and I'm holding
four medicine
bottles I don't remember taking them
out don't remember going in trying to
handle my proac don't remember going in
trying to handle my
Alprazolam don't remember going in and
trying to handle my satal pram don't
remember trying to go in and handle my
finasteride don't know if I need it but
it's
preventative it's for your
hair so I look and I say oh yeah I'm
taking it I grab the out PRM
dunkaroo and in 10 minutes I feel
fine in 30 more minutes heart starts
palpitating again grab another one
[Music]
dunkaroo and I'm fine but I'm
tired get to
Orlando go to sleep wake up much better
dude remember dunkaroos
never in my life had one
dunar it's ate the [__] out of some
[__] oatmeal cream pies though didn't
I didn't
I uh oh
man back when I didn't know that cream
pie meant spurting in in women I didn't
know
that I didn't know that meant that it
does though I don't know if you know
that cream pie means they don't pull out
and they just go for
it where they don't pull out and they
just you
know they shoot
in oh ma you
look um
anyway that was wild bro that was wild I
can't believe that was the second
hardest panic attack I ever got the
first one was the one when I got my my
nose uh my uh sinus is done in my when I
said I got a nose
job but
yeah
um what's
this oh wait heyy hey player from
BYU shut the f up shut the f
up oh and think I go hey hey hey hey
like that's all crossing the line
dude shut the up he hey hey
hey hey you don't want to go to hell
dude Bo player respons TR talk from
opposing fans
dude
F shut the f up I say [__] God knows you
meant
it just CU it didn't form from your
brain to your
thing also that guy looked
crazy that guy looked like a ren Stimpy
character shut the f up anyway it was
EDC again
dude at least I'm doing all new stuff on
the road [__] yeah dude completely
different than the don't push me to oh
[__] or I mean I'm sorry completely
different than grow or die [__] yeah
dude he couldn't help
it oh he couldn't help it he thought
he'd do half and half but he couldn't
help it did
he oh oh he couldn't help it oh he tried
to do [__] half and half but then his
mom went and broke broke her hip and he
did some [__] material on that now a
[__] now he's got a whole full hour out
[__] I don't know man I just have a good
time on stage and I love you
[__] that come out
man I love you [__] that come
out and I love when you [__]
listen to this podcast and I love it
dude I do all new stuff on the road and
uh we I went to Fort Myers dude and that
place is The Truman Show I'll tell you
that
much they had a restaurant called
Capones dude and it said on the thing I
love it man dude I had to eat there I
had to eat there because it said pizza
so good it should be
illegal not how it
works not how the law
works what' you get
freeze what's on
that what's on that mushrooms and
sausage freeze get him did you get the
pizza you better hope he says [__]
czone he's looking at the the [__]
the the people in
the the plane closes officers are just
like all right we're watching
them you got them
yeah he's got the menu see what he's got
see what he's going to
get
you order a dieet
Coke okay
okay I got a visual you got him yeah
Frank got a
visual here comes the
waiter she's asking she's asking him
something all right got
it still got that shot Frank got him my
out what'd he get okay can't tell what
you ordered the plane clothed
mve we saw him got the table across but
there's a bus that went by caught noise
couldn't make couldn't make out what he
said freak
[Music]
got I want to see what she comes here
she's bringing the pizza she's bringing
the pizza take him
out freeze get down get him down success
oh we [__] we actually killed him oh
[__] ah [__] him [__] his corpse
um where's
cops
necrophiliac uh ttic cops
um so anyway dude uh I love [__] like
that dude I love dumb [__]
dude did you say
pepperoni we thought you said peoni we
can't tell you need a visual we a visual
on the
meats
um fall back it's a calzone
um fall back it's a chicken parmesan
fall back it's fall back it's
[Laughter]
[Music]
picata abort it's millon days
um abort
[Laughter]
Mission abort Mission it's mozzarella
sticks and a die Coke aort
Mission head on over to Pizza Hut Frank
I got him in a visual got a pizza shoot
him shoot him and [__] the
[Laughter]
corpse I'm on top of the Kinkos I'm on
top of the Kinkos and I got a visual
Frank you got a visual got a visual
y Here Comes be it's a deep dish shoot
him and [__] the
corpse get them put it in [__] him cream
pie there we go all right we're out
great great deal today guys great deal
got him with the gunshot and the cream
pie got him with the cream
pie dude it said piz is so good it could
be it should be illegal dude and anyway
nothing is more Italian nothing is more
Italian than being from Florida dude I I
swear to God
people think the most of time
[__] are from Italy no then
they think they're from New York no New
Jersey no Florida dude
Florida the most Italiano
[__] dude in the [__] place Capones
the handles the door handles were
[__] tommy
guns dude they were tommy guns like kids
go to this place you know get to open
like this it was so there was like spiky
and [__] with the
scope anyway went there got a [__]
Italian sandwich dude nothing is like
[__] I was by myself dude and I ate a
[__] Italian hot pressed panini
sandwich let me tell you something dude
it wasn't that good but when I walked by
and I saw a guy eating it I was like I'm
getting that I'm going to [__] there
I'm getting that [__] because why
because I make decisions dude like told
you the beginning of the podcast that's
how I do this all
right so anyway dude I did that and then
did the show and it was fun
man and then one of the nights
dude man I went to bed I fell asleep you
know how sometimes you fall asleep
before you fall asleep like I fell
asleep at like I don't know what it was
12:30 and
then woke up at like
6:00 a.m. it was like a weird time to
fall but I was like jet lagged you know
and
um
9 no okay no oh I talked to Kristen at
1:00
a.m. fell asleep woke up at 6:00
a.m. nine missed calls from Kristen oops
now
palpitations oh
o scared as [__]
oops tried to call her back what the
[__] of course what happened well did
she pick up wait a minute no my wife's a
woman she
didn't the thing is she went to sleep
with a ringer off
ah but she called me nine times but why'
she do that ah cuz my wife's a
woman so I call at 6: a.m. she doesn't
she doesn't pick up
great do I go back to
sleep
kinda until when 11:30 but I don't fall
asleep I'm just laying there finally I
call at 11:30 she picks up hey sorry
baby hello hey babe what's up he what's
up is you called me nine times is
everything okay is the house on fire oh
no no no I I was at a I went to a house
party what come again I talked to you
about one dude she went to a house party
with her
friend and like got super faded or
something I don't know if she got faded
or not saw she was like Yeah The Chain
Smokers were there I was like what's
going
on anyway she's alive it's all
good scared the [__] out of me though
huh I said babe what the [__] you were
at a party she yeah I said did you cheat
on me H we had a
laugh
um bro
this this uh movie trailer
bro
Bruh Bruh
wait what's this before I even go to
that movie trailer what's
this
[Music]
ah yeah
oh the reveal Gucci game
oh you Gucci
gang Gucci gang Gucci gang Gucci gang
Gucci gang the last Lady
dude the last lady
just what is it you
know um it's Russian everything about
that so Russian can't even believe it
you can't even get that what that kid's
wearing you can't even get it anywhere
else if you have that you're in Russia
you walk out of Russia it immediately
gets sucked back into Russia that outfit
um how about how the Marvels made the
worst had the worst
MCU opening weekend of all time but we
knew that was going to happen dude
nobody wants to go see this movie
because nobody really cares about the
Brie Larson superhero whatever that one
is I'm not saying Brie larsson's bad I
don't think she's bad but this character
nobody cares about and then there's two
other women in the movie that nobody
knows the once Mighty studio just took a
major L after the Marvel's made an
anemic 47 million at the domestic Bo box
office oh god dude it cost 200 million
to make
this
uh wow I guess they thought Captain Marv
there's just too many too many of them
too much many of them um and then and I
love how people are going to be like
well it was because we couldn't promote
because of the strike dude eat my ass
nobody wants to go see Marvel what's it
called
Marvel's
like the Black Adam one and the and the
other one the Shazam 2 was even this is
worse than
them and anic 47 million though that's
pretty crazy so much
money go to holler. christalia if you
want to purchase a 10-word ad on the
podcast forgot to say that a little
earlier how about what this [__]
thing is screeing I guess it was in the
80s it looks like it at
least skiing on dirt with no skis and
just poles and and going to break your
[__]
ankles so dangerous most years of
screeing season's fairly long about 365
days dude or until you break your back
whichever happens first I mean flipping
around this is so irresponsible you know
a screw report here would read some
loose dirt with occasional Mogul on a
granite base of 8,000
Miles the group is raising money by
selling limited Partnerships to build a
scree lift a scree lodge and a scree
shop didn't come to once they sell all
the Partnerships they'll Cash Out buy a
condo in Maui and take up board
sailing I mean dude the the way they're
jumping and putting why every time they
jump they have to put their [__]
click their Le their their their heels
up like they're in a Toyota
commercial that's so stupid
dude wow that bit where I was pretending
I was under cover cops really made me
tired holy [__] [__] dude I mean I
just got [__] all the jet lagged when
I [__] did that when I did the them
[__] the corpse and [__] Tesla will
sue you for $50,000 if you try to resell
your cyber truck in the first year man
this bananas huh the world's just
bananas you know the world is just
[__]
bananas how are they goingon to do
that Tesla's cybertruck will make its
debut to Consumers who pre-order the
vehicle on November 30th Tesla has
released the sale terms for its longwa
so you you paid for this why can't you
sell it oh because they don't want you
to make money off it owners of the Eevee
pickup truck are banned from reselling
their vehicles during the first
year
wow
customers set to receive the first Tesla
cyber trucks this November can't resell
their vehicles during the first year
according to Tesla's terms and
conditions Tesla added a section titled
for cybertruck only to its motor
vehicle uh so that's part of it then you
agree that you will not sell or
otherwise attempt to sell the vehicle
within the first year following your
vehicle's delivery
date what the [__] this is
crazy
this cyber truck let's look at
it you know what it looks like bad
CGI hey guys I need this Lane clear
honestly it
looks okay from the
outside but the inside's going looks so
bad dude the inside of [__] Teslas
are sh dog [__] I don't care that they
have a whole computer screen on it
they're dog dog [__] I'd rather bring my
whole computer in my [__] cool
car you we all have iPhones that's the
thing too people be like yeah but the
thing about the Tesla is it's really
fast and also has a computer screen in
the thing I'll just I have an iPhone and
I don't need to go that fast there's
potholes everywhere I don't like Teslas
dude make them better they're the new
Priuses remember remember Prius they
still make them probably but like they
were dog [__] they were dog [__] they
looked dog [__] they were good for the
environment okay cool I would love to
help the environment but I'm not going
to look like I'm rolling around in dog
[__] make them cooler put a fin on it or
some
[__] put the shark on the side like the
old
planes it's going to take 18 months for
this truck to become in the positive I
guess and I don't [__] care at all
period about any of that but I talk
about it but I talked about
it
screeing come on
dude sit
down signs
off SE Bel signs off it's not a
disturbance once you once you it's right
here babe seat I am I'm have a seat okay
so watch me bless him so I used to sing
on planes a long time ago I just found
out I'm up for two gramys my very first
time you
guys my name is Bobby
storm and I'm up for two Grammys I sing
for the Lord and my song is out on all
platform for it's called we can't forget
them Michael McDonald cleared it
War
dude are you [__] me dude hey
imagine imagine us
there I'm up for two grand
hey uh no you're not you know what I'm
saying warranty is on the original
record as well the Asian back regor I
want to share this with you guys I
wanted to do it when I first got on the
plane but I was like you know I haven't
done this in a while I've gotten to the
next status so are even to be quiet but
they're enjoying it so
why oh you need to be
quiet oh sitting here can I please I'm
not enjoying it so I'm asking you can
you be
quiet that's a yes or no uh answer
please am I going to go to jail if I
don't can you please answer my question
are you willing and able to be quiet
right now I'm doing what the Lord is
telling me to do I'm
ask what if he was like [__] me
too you a question yes or no I'm your
flight leader I need you to follow my
instruction okay my instructions for you
to answer my question are you able to be
quiet what do you guys
think my dud a democracy a [__]
Mutiny dude Mutiny this is like Crimson
Tide the
movie I'm asking you ma'am what do you
guys think dude everyone just go like
this you guys what do you guys say okay
oh you
best believe if I was there I would say
let her
sing from the back dude me oh my
lord
[Music]
oh my Lord you know what [__] this I
actually got it and that I will walk 500
miles and I will walk dude I would have
taken it over if you're not able to be
to follow my instruction you will not be
taking this flight ah okay are you able
to be quiet if that's the case then
that's fine if you were the person in
charge of it all I'm your flight leader
yes if you're the person in charge of it
all then that's fine all right thank you
so I'll sing it on aone for y'all in the
bag if that's okay all right so the song
is called we can't forget them all right
and you can download it
dude
stop this is a
travesty all right so I'll sing on the
low for you guys now that he's gone
nobody wants to
I don't know the the issue no one else
has ever had an issue but
[Music]
it's I don't know no one's ever had an
issue but
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's
don't
[Music]
you
sh dude the hum in the
background I can't
even
[Music]
looking do it
interc this your captain speaking um so
we're going to be flying into
Nashville so just so you know if you're
on this flight you have been thank you
so much got to clap on the low I know
thank you so much so look up Maverick
City Maverick city has an album out
right now do it right now they are a
contemporary gospel group and I have
been blessed to be a part of that album
that's called we can't forget them yep
we can't forget them and it's available
everywhere it's on the Billboards so you
know people like that you know they
Spirits a little they can't accept it
but I'm here to spread what God needs me
to spread I'm here to spread that
because that's what's got dude I can't
believe this is still going dude this is
still going me where I am I quit my job
and October of last year dude who cares
dude
wow I really wonder what I would do if I
was there and I just went out by faith
and now here I am so remember to space
and Chase the storm all right nobody is
talking to her
right y BBI storm like the weather thank
you guys for sure thank you guys and
Bobby you're a what now a two time
Grammy nomin yes just as of today two
time Grammy nominated with Maverick City
the Maverick way thank you thank
you dude that's the number one cringiest
thing I think I've ever seen in my life
she's also
not
nominated dude
she's not nominated she appears on the
Maverick City Music EP that's nominated
for best gospel
album but she's not
nominated dude that
was I've never I've never one time when
I was at Mel's
Diner I saw really young woman walk up
to Buster rymes who was there also at
Mel's Diner and she started singing to
him and it was so bad she wasn't good
and he didn't even look up and it was so
hard to watch and this
was much longer than that I wish I was
there dude dude I want to I so I'm GNA
watch it again I'm not g to watch it
again on the podcast because I know
people probably don't want me to hear it
again but my God I cannot [__]
believe holy [__]
dude what the Bobby storm dude she's my
favorite artist from now on she's my
favorite singer she's my favorite singer
but it's
[Music]
this dude
that's
breathtaking that experience thank you
Bobby storm thank you so much for that
bre breathtaking
experience
how does this guy do the levitation
man all right you know the the [__]
music you know bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang iy
can levitate huh guy would have been
killed if it was the
1600s um all right I guess that's it
dude you guys thank you very much for
listening oh my God I I got to watch
that thing again um I appreciate you
guys if you want to watch the rest of
the video that's it for YouTube if you
want to watch the rest of it go to
patreon.com / christalia thank you very
much and uh remember to go watch my
special chris.com it's called grow or
die and uh check it all out the ne grow
die merch is up there too go get it
thanks a lot
[Music]
guys